en química existe un concepto llamado
calor específico el calor específico es
particular para cada sustancia es decir
cada sustancia tiene un calor específico
diferente y se define como la cantidad
de calor o de energía necesaria para que
un gramo de sustancia se eleve un grados
celsius
a veces la definición puede decir que es
para que una determinada masa de una
sustancia se pueda elevar un grados
celsius pero yo lo estoy haciendo un
poco más particular un gramo de una
sustancia un grados celsius entonces
esto nos dice que tanta energía
necesitamos para calentar algo veamos
por ejemplo el agua si queremos aumentar
la temperatura del agua un grados
celsius aumentar un grados celsius y
aquí tenemos una cierta cantidad de
calor que será diferente al que
tendremos en otra sustancia como por
ejemplo arena supongamos que aquí
tenemos arena y si queremos elevar su
temperatura un grados celsius
necesitaremos una cantidad de calor
diferente resulta que en el caso de la
arena si queremos elevar su temperatura
un grados celsius
necesitamos menos calor del que
necesitaremos para elevar la temperatura
del agua supongamos que esto representa
un gramo de agua y este es un gramo de
arena para elevar la temperatura 1
grados celsius aquí necesitamos más
calor que acá y eso es porque el agua
tiene un calor específico mayor mayor
aquí tenemos un calor específico
relativamente mayor mientras que la
arena en comparación al agua tiene un
calor específico menor
menor menor calor específico entonces si
queremos aumentar la temperatura un
grados celsius de un gramo de cada uno
necesitamos aplicar más energía en el
agua que en la arena o si ponemos la
misma cantidad de energía en los dos
aumentaremos más la temperatura de la
arena que del agua ahora el calor
específico del agua tiene un nombre
especial a lo mejor ya lo han visto
antes al calor específico del agua se le
conoce como caloría caloría tal vez ya
lo han escuchado antes esto se encuentra
mucho en las etiquetas nutricionales de
la comida pero voy a hacer una
aclaración las calorías que tienen que
ver con las etiquetas nutricionales de
la comida en realidad son kilocalorías
por ejemplo si alguien les ofrece un
helado voy a dibujarlo
si alguien les ofrece helado y les dice
que tiene 500 calorías 500 calorías si
pensamos en términos del calor
específico en realidad son 500
kilocalorías kilocalorías hay varias
formas en las que podemos pensar sobre
estas 500 kilocalorías por ejemplo este
helado tiene la energía suficiente para
elevar la temperatura de 500 kilogramos
de agua un grado celsius o si lo quieren
ver en términos humanos como los humanos
adultos son en general personas entre 50
60 o 70 kilogramos aproximadamente
supongamos 50 kilogramos un hombre
adulto compuesto de 50 kilogramos de
agua claro hay otras cosas que le dan
peso pero esta vez supongamos que tiene
aproximadamente 50 kilogramos de agua en
su cuerpo en el caso de arriba elevamos
la
altura 1 grados celsius pero en este
caso aumentaría 10 grados celsius eso es
lo que sucede en nuestro cuerpo el calor
de nuestro cuerpo es causado
parcialmente por la comida un poco es
para el proceso de nuestro movimiento y
de las diferentes funciones de los
músculos el cerebro y todo lo que hace
nuestro cuerpo pero otra parte es para
producir calor a veces puede ser un
subproducto de ese movimiento y a veces
solo es por la producción de calor
entonces las 500 calorías que vemos en
la etiqueta de la comida en realidad son
500 kilocalorías y esa energía es
suficiente para elevar la temperatura o
un grado celsius de 500.000 gramos de
agua recuerden 500 kilogramos son
500.000 gramos de agua o podemos decir
que elevamos la temperatura de 50 mil
gramos de agua 10 grados celsius
entonces para el agua usaremos el nombre
especial caloría y ya dijimos que
significa una kilocaloría pero este
concepto de que el agua tiene un calor
específico más alto respecto a otras
sustancias como la arena en realidad
tiene gran impacto en el clima de hecho
es una de las razones por las que en
general es más bonito vivir cerca de la
costa dibujaré una línea costera la
dibujaré como si la viéramos desde
arriba esta parte es la tierra está
hecha de arena y algunas otras cosas y
en esta parte tenemos agua
vamos a ver primero pensemos en la costa
como si estuviéramos en el verano cuando
hace más calor imaginemos un día soleado
aquí tenemos el sol que está irradiando
energía calienta todo lo que toca y
vamos a suponer que todo esto se
encuentra a la misma temperatura puede
haber un poco de variación y reciben la
misma cantidad de luz solar pero como el
agua tiene un calor específico más alto
eso hace que el agua se caliente menos
voy a escribir esta parte está menos
caliente menos caliente
y esta parte donde hay más arena estará
más caliente esta parte está más
caliente por eso cuando estamos en una
costa el aire se ve afectado por todo
con lo que está en contacto como aquí
está en contacto con el agua que está
menos caliente lo mismo ocurrirá con el
aire especialmente el que viene del
océano si el aire va en esta dirección
entonces en la costa tenemos una brisa
más fresca pero si nos adentramos más el
aire está más caliente aquí tenemos aire
más caliente y aquí el aire no está tan
caliente porque no se calienta tanto con
el agua ahora también podríamos tener el
efecto contrario cuando hablamos de las
épocas más frías del año por ejemplo
supongamos que nos encontramos en una
noche de invierno vamos a dibujarlo
si nos encontramos en una noche de
invierno cuando todo es frío aquí
tenemos la línea costera bueno ahora
tanto la tierra como el agua están
irradiando calor como no hay otra fuente
de calor irradian calor al aire pero si
irradian aproximadamente la misma
cantidad de calor la temperatura de la
tierra caerá mucho más aquí hace más
frío pero el agua no está tan fría el
agua está menos fría porque sin más
energía entra en el agua la temperatura
cambia menos y también puede irradiar la
misma cantidad de calor pero además
pierde menos temperatura así que en el
invierno o en las temporadas más frías
del año el aire que entra en contacto
con el agua estará menos frío que el
aire que se encuentra en la tierra
porque el agua está menos fría que la
tierra por eso es bonito vivir cerca del
agua porque hace menos frío en las zonas
costeras que
tierra adentro y bueno este fenómeno
puede ocurrir en cualquier lugar donde
hay agua pero es más marcado en las
países por ejemplo si ustedes viven en
el océano pacífico supongamos que
vivimos en la bahía de san francisco
voy a dibujarlo aquí tenemos el océano
pacífico este es el océano pacífico y la
bahía de san francisco se ve algo así
aquí está el golden gate famoso puente
de san francisco por si tenían
curiosidad imaginemos que vivimos justo
aquí si nos encontramos aquí en el
verano al mediodía en la costa el
ambiente puede estar 10 o incluso 20
grados menos de lo que está lo mejor por
aquí tierra adentro así que todo esto
tiene un profundo impacto en el clima
ahora por último quizás se han de
preguntar por qué el agua tiene un calor
específico tan alto
bueno regresemos a nuestros viejos
amigos los puentes de hidrógeno si
hablamos de una sustancia sólida aquí
tenemos cualquier sólido supongamos que
tiene una estructura así y como tiene
energía térmica la energía térmica
aumenta la energía cinética de estas
partículas haciendo que vibren más eso
es la temperatura energía cinética
cuando tocamos algo igual está caliente
en realidad es porque las moléculas
están vibrando súper súper rápido y eso
hará que todo vibre más especialmente
cuando hablamos de algo sólido mientras
que en el caso del agua claro cuando
tenemos más energía las moléculas de
agua se moverán más rápido vibrarán más
y tendrán más energía cinética pero para
tener más energía cinética tendrán que
sobrepasar la formación de los puentes
hidrógeno y romperlos imaginen que si
esta molécula de agua quiere moverse en
esta dirección tiene que romper este
puente de hidrógeno pero luego formará
otro puente de hidrógeno y también lo
romperá entonces se necesita mucha
energía para seguir rompiendo los
puentes de hidrógeno y sobrepasar la
fricción de esos puentes de hidrógeno
me gusta decir fricción entre comillas
porque la fricción es un tipo de fuerza
atómica que ocurre a nivel microscópico
así que esta molécula tiene que
sobrepasar eso entonces un poco de este
calor se usa para sobrepasar eso en
lugar de incrementar la energía cinética
de las moléculas individuales o hacer
que vibren para aumentar su temperatura
por eso es que el agua puede almacenar
más calor y por lo tanto su calor
específico es mayor